um one of the
funniest little details in this entire
saga of people protesting at the homes
of not only supreme court justices but
also republican senators is that
republican senator susan collins from
maine
decided to call the police because there
was chalk writing on the sidewalk
outside of her house that this is like
the epitome
of the triggered snowflake and i i
i am sensitive to
others being sensitive about protests at
their homes and we had a very good
conversation on the show yesterday with
coleman hughes about it
but the police over chalk
when you supposedly are a defender of
speech you know the the free the i'm
fine having a good faith conversation
about protests at people's houses i'm
glad to do it
but when you're talking about
free speech absolutists who all of a
sudden say chalk isn't okay that's a bit
of a problem business insider reports
susan collins called the police to refor
report quote defacement of public
property after someone wrote an abortion
rights message in chalk on a public
sidewalk outside of her house
republican senator susan collins of
maine one of just two nominally
pro-choice republicans in the senate
called the police saturday night because
of an abortion rights message written in
chalk in front of her house in bangor
maine
according to the banger daily news
officers responded to a call at 9 20
because a message appeared on the
sidewalk it read susie please mainers
want whpa vote yes clean up your mess
whpa means the women's health protection
bill which would codify abortion rights
afforded by roe v wade into federal law
this is an idea that is an important
idea it's being increasingly discussed
well okay the supreme court can overturn
roe v wade by legal precedent but if we
codify
abortion rights into federal law
it overrides and supersedes that
the message was not overtly threatening
said wade betters a spokesperson for the
police department we are grateful
that susan collins said to the daily
news we are grateful to the banger
police officers and the city public
works employees who responded to the
defacement of public property in front
of our home
guys i mean we're not talking about
poster paint here we're not talking
about spray paint we're talking about
chalk which washes away when it rains
or with a bucket or a hose to call this
defacement this isn't graffiti this is
what kids do all the time they write
with chalk on the sidewalk and um
there's this
i don't want to put all of this on susan
collins because it's not it's not
uniquely her that's the hypocrite here
but it's the big picture of all of this
on the one hand republicans have been so
hesitant to say
the president led and incited an
insurrection and there should be no
consequences on the one hand
and then on the other hand someone wrote
with chalk call the cops
it it's it's one of these uh the the
message here
is a message of authoritarianism
of shutting down public speech and
protest
throwing things in a senator at a
senator of course not absolutely not
going on the property of individuals to
prote absolutely not
um you know what whatever else
no writing with chalk on the sidewalk
that seems like a real problem uh uh
when that now becomes something that
police are called over you can't write
with chalk on a sidewalk
but then you can tell the woman to carry
a pregnancy to term or you don't want to
hold trump accountable for the things
that he did so i think that this is an
outrageous
little micro episode about how the big
picture conversation is kind of missing
the forest for the trees and and by the
way i got a few angry emails after my
conversation yesterday with coleman
hughes from people saying david how can
you be
worried about protests at someone's
house
when women are being disenfranchised
from even being able to make decisions
about their own bodies decisions which
can be life and death they're two
separate situations
i am
you completely overwhelmingly
unequivocally disgusted by what we
believe to be the forthcoming decision
on roe v wade
and i also think there's a good faith
discussion to be had
about protesting at the houses of
supreme court justices these it's okay
to be able to discuss the two things
separately and a handful of people or so
maybe more like a dozen
didn't like that we were even having the
discussion and by the way i also have a
problem with that i know about this
whole we're just asking questions thing
and how it can be used to cover
uh in ways that aren't particularly
productive oh when when tucker says
some people say
ten thousand people died from the covet
vaccine we're just asking questions on
the show i i get the the problem
problematic nature of just asking
questions
but to say i shouldn't even be having
the conversation about protest strategy
and tactics
no guys that that's not uh
that that's not any kind of support of
robust discussion
that i can agree with so maybe rethink
that we will have more on all of these
stories on the david pakman show
instagram which you can find at david
pakman show and if you want to see me
with a big black and white animal was it
a cow or was it a zebra many people are
asking what exactly was the animal i was
pictured with
follow me on my personal instagram at
david.pacman we'll take a quick break
and be right back
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video